hi guys and welcome to the course on
introduction to asp.net core 3.1 my name
is blue King and I would be our
instructor on this introductory course
we will understand the basics of asp.net
core the reason behind its evolution
followed by the new files and folder
structure that have been introduced once
we understand that then we will take a
look at new concepts like middleware
routing tag helpers razor syntax and
much more now with asp.net core there
are two ways to build a web application
first approach is MVC application and
the second approach is razor faceless
application we will be building projects
and put the technologies to understand
how the basics work both the projects
will be built with a basic crud website
which stands for create read update and
delete functionality so we will
understand how to connect with database
and play with entity framework in our
asp.net core web application now before
we start there are some prerequisites
that you should be familiar with I would
say about three months of coding in C
sharp and familiarity with basic sequel
will be sufficient also if you are stuck
with the course my code will be
published on github repository so you
can always follow along with each
lecture and if there is something which
still does not make sense for you you
can always raise a question and I will
be happy to answer that but the first
approach you should take is compare your
code with my version on github and try
to identify the differences this way you
will try to identify the errors yourself
now this would be a basic course on
asp.net code but it will give you a
solid foundation before you dive into
deeper and complex courses
at the end if you are interested in more
detail and in-depth courses I have
courses on both MVC as well as razor
pages with asp.net core and I will also
show you how you can enroll into those
courses for the lowest price that being
said let's get started on this exciting
journey to explore the basics of asp.net
core and I will see you in the next
video in this course we'll be building
two projects first will be a simple
razor project and second one will be our
main project which will use MVC so let
me demo the first project that we'll be
building it's a simple book leash tracer
project in which if you select the book
tab it will display a list of all of the
books now here in the list you can see
two types of tables that is because at
the end here we are using data tables
which makes call of API on top here we
have a simple table using th and TR tags
here when you create a book if you try
to enter without anything we have
validations once you enter the details
to create on your book and you hit the
create button it creates the book and
displays in both the places here when we
use dinner tables if we click Edit here
and if we change something let me make
it a capital W and update it there you
go you can see it is updated if you try
to delete anything it will display a
sweet alert to you that being said we
have multiple ways as I was saying
before in the create new book you'll see
a new page called create but if you go
to absurd it will be the absurd page and
that will be the same page that we'll
use to edit if we go right here
you see it's absurd and if you try here
it will be again an edit page so this is
more of a simplified view and then at
bottom what we see is more of an
advanced view that things that we are
performing crud operations on our book
but this project
is not just that we'll be learning
raisin pages and how page model and page
view comes into the picture so even
though this is a small project for grad
operation there is lots of basic
functionalities and basic fine overview
that you need to understand that link
said let's take a look at the demo of
our final project which is way more
advanced than what you see right here in
this video let me walk you through the
small project that we will build using
MVC this will be a very basic project to
create crud operations on book lists so
right here if you go on book list we
will be using data tables to display all
of the lists from the data base you can
add a new book here you can fill in the
details but let's say if you do not
enter name we see validations that have
been enforced here that thing said you
can create a book and once it is created
you can edit any of the details here and
you can also delete book when you delete
we have nice alerts that you can display
here and once it is successfully deleted
you will also see nice notifications so
this is a great project to get started
with the MVC journey and learn what
asp.net core has to offer in this video
I want to give you a small introduction
on asp.net evolution asp.net code
introduces probably the biggest shift
the platform has experienced so far but
let's take a look at how it has evolved
over time
in 1996 Microsoft released framework
known as ASP which stands for active
server pages or classic ASP with classic
ASP Microsoft made it possible to have
server-side scripting to dynamic web
pages the biggest Revolution came when
Microsoft released dotnet framework
Microsoft introduced asp.net
forms in 2002 this made creation of
webpage similar to the creation of
Windows forma
there are few downsides with web forms
web forms tried to make stateless web
stateful and in order to do that it had
to make lots of changes to make sure web
pages retain their states or their
values automatically view states contain
those values and that resulted in a lot
of data being generated and transferred
with each request sometimes even if it
was not required web forms was the first
version to introduce code behind code
behind is good but it makes testing
difficult because in one line we are
reading from the database and in the
next line we are updating the UI
another common issue was page lifecycle
when requesting a page number of events
were getting fired getting to know all
of these events was quite easy to get it
wrong although there were few downsides
web forms were generally successful to
get site up and running quickly couple
of years later in 2009 Microsoft
released the first version of asp.net
MVC and they tried to Oh welcome most of
the problems with web forms it had
emphasis on separation of concern MVC
code is typically much easier to write
unit tests for MVC was the first edition
when they released it as open source now
a lot of developers did not like MVC
framework because it had its own flaws
when it was created it was built on top
of the components already created for
web forms because of which it was
closely tied to system dot web which was
tied to IAS and eventually Windows on
the other hand web is a bore
quickly and hence Microsoft had to keep
MVC with everything that was changing
also MVC was built before cloud came
into the big picture
even though lot of MVC applications are
still running on cloud but it is still
not built with cloud in mind finally in
June of 2016
Microsoft released asp.net core and this
was the first version now asp.net core
is built on top of the new dotnet core
framework Dartmouth core is the very
first platform version of.net and hence
it is not tied to just windows asp.net
core as compared to the old version of
MVC is not tied to the dotnet framework
assemblies like system dot web ESP
dotnet core team has been very active
with the new versions and then in 2017
they released dotnet core 2 followed by
2.1 and 2.2 in 2018 finally in September
of 2019 asp.net code 3 has been released
which we will be using in this course in
this video let me show you all the tools
that we'll need for this course the
first and most important is Visual
Studio 2019 this is the IDE that we'll
be using you can go on with your studio
Microsoft comm /v yes and you can
download the community version for free
make sure you download the 2019 if it is
2017 dotnet core 3.1 will not work next
what you need is you have to download
the dotnet core 3.1 and install it so if
you go on the Microsoft web site for
dotnet core 3.1 here you can download
the windows for x64 and install it once
you install it then when you create a
project in Visual Studio 2019 you will
see the dotnet code 3.1 option which I
will discuss when we get there
but make sure both of these are
installed after that you'll have to
install the sequel server 2019 you can
use an older version of sequel server
but I would recommend the latest one you
can download it for free for the
developer version once you install
sequel server I also want you to install
the sequel server management studio
which will be a UI to your sequel server
so make sure you install on four of
these features and that are all the
tools that you will need all of these
tools are free so you should not have to
spend anything to install these
software's on your laptop or desktop in
this video I want to show you where you
will find all the code that we'll be
building for that one place will be you
have to go to brew game calm in there I
have courses right now we are on the
free course if you go on the details
if you click course content it will
download the completed code but if you
want lecture by lecture on what was
changed you can click on github code
here it will open up both the projects
that will be building in this course
here if you see the comments they will
be based on the lecture name inside
raiser as well for each lecture you will
see what exactly was changed or updated
and you can make sure that you have
those same things if you face any issue
in a particular lecture so plug in calm
and in there you have to go to the
courses to find out what course you're
on and in there in details you will find
the github link
in this section we will be creating our
very first project it will be a Razer
project and then once we created we will
take a look at the file and folders that
are created with this we will also
understand how an asp.net core
application is started and what are the
files that are involved so let's get
started with all of that from the next
video when you open up we show Studio
2019 it displays a nice page on the left
hand side you can see all the projects
you were working on and on the right
hand side you can see options to create
a new project so right here we'll click
on create a new project and once you do
that it will display all of the
templates that are available out of this
we will select asp.net core web
application if you do not see on the top
view options you can always search for
that template on the top once you find
the asp.net core web application let's
hit the next button and we need a
project name let's call this book list
racer and we'll change the location I'll
page the location where I want to create
this project after that we'll hit the
create button and we'll have more
options for our project in here the
first thing to notice is we have taught
that core and the dotnet framework we
will be using the.net core and what
version we want to use we want to use
the latest version which is asp.net core
3.1 once you select that then we have
few templates here we can go with an
empty application and API project a web
application which uses the razor pages
or we can create an application with MVC
our main project will be built using MVC
but the first project I want to give you
an introduction to razor pages here I
will display a crud operations
so that you can get comfortable with
razor pages because that will be used
inside the identity in a MVC application
so we'll get a basic overview when we
build this project next we have the
authentication here you can select
individual users account for
authentication but right now we do not
want to do that because if we do that
some of the things will already be
configured for us but I want to start
from scratch in this project so we'll
just create a web application with razor
pages then before proceeding we'll make
sure the souls is dotnet core 3.1 and
we'll hit the create button
perfect so with this we have created our
project and we'll be taking a look at
all the files and folder that we created
from the next video in this video we
will take a brief overview on what our
razor pages razor pages have been
introduced in asp.net code 2.0 and since
then they have become the default way of
coding with asp.net cause tank-raised
apple juice is a new feature of asp.net
core that makes coding page focused
scenarios more easier and more
productive they provide a simpler way to
organize code with asp.net core
applications keeping the implementation
logic and view models closer to the view
implementation code raisin pages is not
just for simple scenarios everything
that you can do with MVC you can do the
same using razor pages like routing
models action result tag helpers and so
on
finally razor pages have two parts first
is the UI which is more like the view in
MVC and then we have the page model
which is a combination of models as well
as view models and the controller action
methods let me switch back to the
application that we just created and
give you a quick demo of both the
component so we are on the book list
raiser if we go to solution exploded
inside pages we will have the raiser
pages let's take a look at the index
page if you see the index page has an
arrow and there is dot C as HTML and dot
C sh t ml dot c yes if you open the dot
c as HTML that is the wizard view all
the UI of result pages and then the dot
c yes which is not same as the
code-behind file it is just the naming
convention but this is actually the page
model for our index raiser page you can
see it extends from the page model class
inside this page model we will define
the model for this view right here you
can see it is index model and if you go
on index you can see the class name is
index model in here we have handlers
which are like the controller action
method right now we only have the get
handler that is defined here but we will
be adding a post handler when we want to
post anything from our view or the
raiser page another thing to notice is
the name for the get handler
it is prefixed with the on keyword
similarly if you had a post handler it
would be something like this and which
will have public void on post and will
have the implementation within the
brackets we will undo the change that we
did because I just wanted to show that
right now but as we proceed we will be
implementing the handlers for our raiser
pages in this video let's take a look at
the project configuration file in order
to open that you can right click on the
project not on the solution but on the
project and you have the Edit project
file
or all you can do is double click on the
project name and it will open up the
project file the file name would be the
project name and then the extension dot
C a spirometry project file has been
there since a long time but the format
of the file and how it works is
different in asp.net code 3 in the
initial versions of asp.net call we had
files called project JSON and Uxbridge
the new CS Praja replaces both the file
now right here you can see within
property group we have the target
framework which is net core app 3.0
which is what we are using for this
project the target framework here is
also called a node after that we will be
adding more packages into our solution
let me show you a quick way we go to
tools NuGet package manager solution and
if we go on browse let me install any
first package that we have we have
Newton's soft json so we'll just install
that don't worry we'll come back and
uninstall this but I want to show you
for demo purposes how the project file
will be affected for practices installed
if you go to the project file again now
you see a package reference with
Newton's soft JSON so every time you add
a new gate package a package reference
entry would be added here right now we
only have one of them which we just
added and if we uninstalled us it will
go away if we go back this should be
gone whenever we need to add more
packages we'll be adding more packages
as for our requirement now if you have
worked with previous versions of asp.net
core there was a new gate for meta
package and let me switch to the
presentation for that and here we will
be discussing what was the meta package
and what is done with that the package
has been discontinued and now it
a part of the.net core class library
they are now updated automatically when
you update the version of.net core prior
to 3.0 as I said before the meta package
was included as a nougat package but now
when you install dotnet core on your
Windows or laptop that matter package is
installed automatically also some of the
packages have been moved out from that
meta package like entity framework core
which has been moved to its own nougat
package which we will be installing in
the future videos so that was a brief
overview of where the meta package is
now with dot that code 3 you will no
longer see the meta package microsoft
asp net core dot app it has been moved
within the dotnet framework so it is
installed automatically when you install
dotnet core so that gives a brief
overview of the CS branch file mainly it
is to reference all of the nougat
packages and the target framework in
this video we will be taking a look at
the properties in our folder if you
expand the properties you will see a
file called launch settings start JSON
this file tells research to do what to
do when you press the Run button right
here on the top by default we have few
profiles here by default we have few
profiles here the first one is the ILS
Express which will launch IRS Express
which will host the application and
start a browser that will hit the URL it
will also set the environment variables
to development in this case we can
detect the environment variables and
make changes based on that example if it
is development we will load the full CSS
and if it is production then we will
load the minified version of CSS there
is also a section to configure the iis
Express
here you can set the launch variables
here if you scroll down further we have
another profile called as publish racer
which is the project name it will run
the application as a command line
application so the internal Kestrel
which is internal web server would be
used then a browser would be started
which hits the URL these can also be set
by going into the properties of the
project not the solution and if we go on
debug we have all the profiles right
here and you can set the environment
variables URL SSL and other
configuration we will not be altering
any of this but I wanted to show you an
overview of what it is and where you can
change that also inside the run here you
will see all the profiles so you can
select anyone to run your application
the next thing that we'll be taking a
look is the www root folder if you
expand this you will see folders for CSS
J s level this is a new thing that has
been introduced with asp.net core and
this has been created automatically in
this folder we will be placing all the
static files like images CSS JavaScript
and also static HTML this folder is the
root folder for our website none of the
code files that we'll be creating will
go inside this folder so you shouldn't
be placing any C sharp or razor files
here this folder has been created with
an idea of having a nice separation
between code files and the static files
since we created the application using
MVC template we can see that visual
studio has already placed few bootstrap
CSS and other static files for us if you
expand CSS you see site dot CSS with GS
you have site our chairs
and inside the lip folder we have
bootstrap jQuery validations and some
other scripts now the reason we have all
these CSS and JavaScript by default is
we created the web application as a
razor page if we selected an empty
application we would have to add all
this files by ourself if you want to
explore that option you can go ahead
with that but we'll be leaving right it
is when we'll be adding more CSS or
JavaScript we'll always do that inside
rww root folder so that is the one place
for all of your static files in this
video we will be taking a look at the
pages folder inside our razor project so
the main folder inside any racer project
is the pages folder in here we will have
all the pages that we want for our
website inside the pages folder using a
shared folder and if you expand this we
have underscored layout and validation
scripts partial now the name of these
two ways or pages starts with an
underscore which means they are partial
views now partial pages is something
like user components which means you can
reuse them in multiple places in your
website the first one here underscore
layout is the default master page for
your application so if you open this up
right here you see we have the header
for our application you scroll down we
have the main part and we have the
footer we also have the scripts that we
want throughout our application and if
you scroll up right here we have the CSS
files you can of course change the
default page that you have for the
master page but we will keep it the same
and right now it is underscored layout
next what we have is validation scripts
partial here we have just included the
JavaScript or jQuery that we will use
for validations
in the pages where we want to include
that we can just include this partial
page after that outside of the shared
folder we have the view import now with
dotnet Core 2 pointer when above we have
tag helpers and we will understand in
detail about tag helpers in just a
little while but in the view import you
defined that you want to include tag
helpers in your application by adding
this one line which starts with active
tag helper you can also add custom tag
helpers here if you create your own tag
helpers and you want to register for
this application you can also add your
custom tag helpers that you want to be
used in your application if for some
reason you only want to use tag helpers
for some features rather than defining
this at global level
you can also define it at individual
page but I like to define it at the
global level in underscore view inputs
so that when I need it it is already
present after that we have the
underscore view start file and here we
define which is the master page that
we'll use for our application right here
you can see underscore layout has been
defined after that what we have the rest
we are the actual result pages so you
can think about whatever be discussed so
far are more related to configuration
master page and user component then we
have the edit page index page and the
privacy page now if you open up the
indexed RCS HTML right here you see the
UI or the user interface with HTML and
CSS but where is the page behind or the
model defined here in MVC we used to
have controllers but we do not have that
anymore in the Razr pages so if you
expand this you see there is index dot
CSH DML dot CS and this is inheriting
from page model and the name here is
index model if you go to the index page
you will see the model
it's the same name so what it will be
defined inside the page model here will
be used as the model for the index
raiser page this page model will be a
code behind for our index page this is
nowhere as close to what we had in the
classic asp.net code behind this is
completely rewritten and in a completely
different format and we will call this
dot CS file as the page model and the
dot CS HTML will be the view or the Razr
page now that we have a brief overview
of where what code goes let's see if
outing in the next video when we will
see the index privacy and the
application coming along one of the
top-level considerations for the
developer of a server-side web
application framework is how to match
URLs to the resources on the server so
that the correct one processes the
request the most straightforward
approach is that you map URLs to the
physical files on the desk and this is
the approach that has been implemented
by the asp.net core team for RAZR pages
framework now there are some rules on
how RAZR pages framework matches URL to
files and how rules can be customized to
give different results
if needed the first rule is that raiser
pages needs a root folder by default the
folder has been named pages and its
location is inside the root folder of
the web application project you can
configure another folder as the root
folder in the application configuration
services method inside the startup class
but that is beyond the scope of this
course so we believe that as the default
page if we have any requirements that we
had to change that we will of course
take a look at that let's switch back to
the application that we have right here
you see the root folder is the pages
folder and all of the pages
besides inside that of course we can add
areas here and we can add pages inside
the areas folder then that will become
the root folder for the application
another rule is that the file extension
should not be included inside the URL
path so right here you see indexed RCS
HTML inside the URL we will only mention
index then let me switch back to the
presentation and the third rule is that
index dot CSS HTML is the default file
which means if a file name is missing
from the URL the request will be mapped
to index dot CSS HTML inside that folder
now let's take a look at few examples in
the first example we have www.hs holder
and then look for index dot CS HTML page
since we have not defined anything in
the URL index is the default page in the
second example we have wwwo main com
forward slash index again in this it
will look for the same index page inside
the pages folder because we have
explicitly defined the index page
finally we have www dot Omega /ik out
now here it has two ways to find the
page first it will try to find inside
the pages folder first it will try to
find inside pages folder a file named as
account dot C sh t ml if it finds that
it will render that if it doesn't find
that then it thinks that account could
be a subfolder name under pages so it
will check inside the pages folder if
there is a folder called account and
inside that it will try to find index
dot c es HTML so we have fewer examples
here for routing let's see this in
action let's go to our project and run
the application
here you can see the URL is localhost
and we do not have anything else so that
means by default it is loading the index
page if we go back to our application
solution Explorer double click index you
can see the text is welcome and that is
what we are seeing right here if we
explicitly defined index here it will
still load the same page now if we click
on privacy here you can see it is adding
privacy and if we go back to the
solution privacy is inside pages so you
can directly access that let me stop the
application and show you something else
I'll add a new folder and I'll call this
with my name plug-in here and I will
move privacy inside procane let's run
our application and try to access the
privacy again if we click here it will
not load anything because privacy
doesn't exist in the same location in
order to access that you have to type
rogaine forward slash privacy and with
this it loads the privacy page correctly
so that way you can see that the linking
of all the pages is exactly what you see
here I'll move the privacy back inside
the pages folder and I'll delete my
folder not renamed perfect so this was a
brief overview on how routing works and
we'll be using more tag helpers and
routing as we proceed with the course in
this video we will take a look at tag
helpers tag helpers are brand new to
asp.net core Microsoft looked at the
success around the other libraries like
angularjs react and others and decided
that implementing an angular directive
like experience in the new asp.net was
so important to the adoption of asp.net
core and because of which they decided
to create tag helpers from crowns
Tagg helpers enable server-side code to
participate in creating and rendering
HTML elements inside the reserved files
though there are similarities between
angular directives and tag helpers there
is a major difference tag helpers are
for server-side rendering while
angularjs directives are all about
client-side rendering now you might be
wondering how tag helpers are compared
to HTML helpers if you have worked with
previous versions of.net core HTML
helpers are really just methods
throughout your razor markup tag helpers
on the other hand are very focused
around HTML elements and much more
natural to use now let's switch back to
the application and let's take a look at
few tag helpers that we already have in
here let's go on the index page and we
do not have any tag helpers associated
inside here but if we go on underscored
layout there should be plenty of tag
helpers right here you can see the tag
helpers ASP area and ASP page when we
have to redirect to any of the reserve
pages we will use the tag helper ASP
page and then we'll define the path
right here we want to go to the index
page which is inside the pages folder
hence we have defined forward slash
index then if you scroll down with more
navigations we again have those tag
helpers if you scroll down further right
here we have another tag helper and with
the script we have the ASP append
version tag helper we will be using more
tag helpers for labels forms and all of
the buttons but we'll do that when we
proceed but the main thing about tag
helpers is you can use your regular HTML
tag and you can just append a tag helper
like you can with other JavaScript
frameworks also I want to show you few
similarities that we have
between the HTML helpers and tag helpers
both HTML helpers and tag helpers
perform the same functionality but here
you can see that the label tag is so not
HTML friendly for HTML helper but when
you use tag helper you'll be using the
same label tag class attributes all you
have to do is add ASP for tag helper if
you do not understand all of this right
now
do not worry as we proceed and start
coding this will start to make much more
sense in classic asp.net code in the
system dot web assembly took care of
starting the application and global dot
asex had the methods in which you could
provide custom logic the steps needed to
start up an application are now
determined by you and that starts with
the program class file the program class
contains a main method which is the
entry point for the application when the
runtime executes the application it
looks for this main method and concered
most dotnet applications start up using
the main method the application
initially starts as a command-line
application the main method configures
asp.net core and starts it let's switch
back to the application and take a look
at this so right here we'll go to
solution Explorer and we have the
program dot CS in here you see we have a
main method here the configuration is
done by calling create host builder
which is a method in the program class
that returns I host builder on that
object build and cron is called and from
that point onwards this application has
become an asp.net core application
create host builder calls create default
builder on a static web host class that
configures the way
host using defaults it deals with the
configuration on how asp.net court deals
with web server configuration files
routing and so on you can see on top of
the default configuration done by the
create default builder the web builder
is also configured to use a startup
class file and if you go on the startup
class file by pressing f12 here or you
can go to solution explorer
startup class file right here you can
see startup course is a simple class not
deriving from any other class the
runtime will by convention call two
methods here first is the configure
services and we have the configure
method let's take a look at both of them
and the startup class file in the next
video
as we saw in the previous clip the
one-time execute Smee
which among other thing configures the
startup class
the runtime will call methods configure
services and configure here we have an
IEEE configuration object that is being
passed as dependency injection to the
startup class here with the configure
services it is written this method gets
called by runtime it is used to add
services to the container
the purpose of configured services
method is to configure dependency
injection dependency injection in
classic asp.net was optional in asp.net
core it forms an integral part of the
asp.net itself this method adds services
to the application to make them
available you get the service collection
object that is injected into the method
as parameter now you can use this to
build on the services that would be
available to this application examples
of the services would be entity
framework or identity service MVC and
many more by default you will have the
add raiser pages available you will not
have the Razr compilation here so do not
worry it should look like this
you will only have the address and pages
and this is because when we created the
project we select type that we want the
raiser pages the other method is the
country girl method and here this method
is used to configure the HTTP request
pipeline the pipeline specifies how the
application should respond to HTTP
requests pipeline is composed of
individual parts called middleware let
me switch to a presentation to explain
that pattern now in any general scenario
what people have is we will have a
browser and then we will have a pipeline
in which we will make a request and we
will get back a response the individual
parts that make up
pipeline are called middle layers let's
consider a few of the middlewares that
we can add in a pipeline one of them can
be MVC and then we can also add
authentication and static files you
should notice that when we add
authentication middleware it should be
done before we add MVC and the order is
important the reason is we do not want
to load MVC and then find out that user
is not authenticated we also have to
configure a middleware for static files
in our project like HTML files images
CSS or JavaScript files now when the
data travels through the pipeline it
gets manipulated by individual
middlewares
and so does the response or the result
let's take a look at a 10,000 foot image
of what happens when this request is
made in the next video so when the
request is made from the browser it
first arrives at a web server like ías
ía ías will then invoke the dotnet
runtime which would load the CLR and
then look for an entry point in your
application it will find that in the
main method of the program class and
execute it which starts the internal web
server in your application we will have
cash flow in our application the mean
method and the started class would
configure the application and the
request would be routed from iis to
Cashville
and then it will be pushed to the
application after that it will be
processed by all the middlewares and the
generated response will be founded back
to the cached world which will route it
back to the IAS that will finally
produce the response on the browser this
is much more efficient than the old
system duck web approach classic system
relied heavily on system dot web which
was tied to a is but using a pipeline a
pro
we only plug in the middle where's that
we need everything we plug in is in a
separate assembly exposed in a new gate
now since system Duckworth was tied to
IAS and IAS is tied to Windows that is
the reason you cannot run classic
asp.net on other web servers than IAS
and Windows now since that is no longer
the case
asp.net core applications can be run on
web servers and other operating systems
one thing you should keep in mind is
that there are two web servers one is
external like Ras or a partially or
Linux and that is also an internal web
server hosted by your application the
request from the external web server are
passed to the internal web server and
other way around
you can choose different internal web
server but most common is cash flow
since it has first-class support in
asp.net core cash flow is a lightweight
web server which can only execute the
request because of which you need
external web server to configure other
options like security hashing and so on
this was a brief overview on how
middleware and pipeline comes to the
picture let me switch back to the
application that we were looking at and
inside the configure method you can see
we have plugged in multiple middlewares
using app and then the middleware name
we check if it is development we want to
use the developer exception page else we
want to use just a generic error page
then we have the HTTP redirection mirror
where we have the middleware for static
files because of the static files
middleware we will be able to use the
CSS JavaScript and images that we will
add inside the WW root folder then we
have the app dot use routing
and then we have AB dot use
authorization finally we have used
endpoints with dotnet core 3 they have
introduced endpoint routing in which you
can configure multiple routes we will
understand why we need this M we can
configure more than one endpoints here
for different technologies which we will
see in upcoming videos
but right now the main thing to consider
is you can see how we are plugging in
different middlewares
now we have used the terminology
middleware quite a few time
so let's actually understand what
middlewares are now that we have seen
the overview of application flow let's
understand middleware and pipeline in
much more detail whenever an HTTP
request comes in something must handle
that request so it eventually results in
an HTTP response those pieces of code
that handles the requests and results in
a response make up the request pipeline
what we can do is configure this request
pipeline by adding middleware which our
software components that are assembled
into an application pipeline to handle
request and response so typically a
browser is going to send a request to
your server and that request is going to
be interpreted by the server and handled
by some piece of software
now first that request is attached to
something called as the context object
as a part of software that manages this
context in our case it would be asp.net
chord middleware you can essentially
think of it as a pipeline which is a
series of pipes that is going to
determine what is going to happen to the
context
so first the request is passed along the
first pipe and the first part interprets
the context and checks out the request
and determines if
that is some type of response needed and
attach that to the context if there is
no immediate response that should be
handed back to the server then the
context is simply passed along to the
next pipe in the pipeline this continues
again to the next piece of the
middleware whatever it might be and it
goes on till it reaches the very last
pipe now it is also possible that at end
of the pipe line no response has been
formed and that will cause a 404 not
found and written back to whoever
originated the request however it is
possible that in any one or more of
these Middle West there may be a
response that needs to be passed back
and it could happen in any of the pipes
so sometimes it could happen that
middleware would not pass the context
along the next piece but rather says ok
I have a response that I need to send
back but typically your context will go
all the way through the pipeline to the
end where the last piece of middleware
sends a response which gets back through
the pipeline to the server and then the
server sends back the response to the
browser this is very simplified version
of how request works let me just walk
you through that again in a brief
overview so that this makes complete
sense when the request comes in to the
server the server then accesses the
darknet code framework and puts the
request into a context object the
context gets passed along through the
middleware and if the middleware has a
response anywhere along the way then it
will attach that response to the context
object and then pass that context object
back through the pipeline to the server
and then the server sends back the
response to the browser now keep in mind
the order of pipeline is important it
always gets passed from the first to the
last a collector
we'll be authentication middleware if
the middleware component finds that a
quest isn't authorized it will not pass
it to the next piece of the middleware
but it will immediately return an
unauthorized response it is hence
important that authentication middleware
is added before other components that
shouldn't be triggered in case of an
unauthorized request we will be adding
more middlewares in our project but
we'll do them as we face the requirement
for that another file that we have in
our project is AB setting start JSON all
of the application settings are
contained in this file and any changes
to the app settings dot JSON file will
require restarting of the iis
administration to take effect let's
switch back to the application and take
a look at this file so if we go here we
have the app setting start JSON file in
here right now you see we only have
logging we have log level and few other
details we will be adding more settings
here for connection string and also if
you add new other details like maybe
something related to dependency if there
are some security keys or anything you
can also add them here you can also
store them remotely on a server but app
settings is generally a place where you
have them when you're initially
developing in the future videos we will
be adding more settings here like
connection strings and we'll be
accessing these variables inside the
start of class file when we use
dependency injection so that's the brief
overview of the app settings to JSON
file asp.net course supports dependency
injection software design pattern which
is a technique for achieving inversion
of control between classes and their
dependencies now you might be wondering
what is a UC or inversion of control
container ioc container is a framework
for
lamenting automatic dependency injection
it manages object creation and it's
lifetime and also injects dependencies
to their class ioc container creates an
object of the specified class and also
injects all of the dependency objects
through constructor property or method
at runtime and disposes it at
appropriate time this is done so that we
do not have to create and manage the
objects manually support for dependency
injection is built into asp.net core in
asp.net cool both framework services and
application services can be injected
into your classes rather than being
tightly coupled dependency injection is
a design pattern in which a class or
object has its dependent classes
injected rather than creating them
directly
dependency injection can help developers
decoupled the different pieces of their
application let's try to see this with
an example
we have Bob here who has been thinking
about going on hiking so he makes a list
of all the supplies like maps
flashlights protein bars etc and puts
them in a backpack
now next day when he goes on hiking he
takes the backpack with him this bag
acts as a container so during the hike
whenever he needs anything he takes it
out of the container and uses them this
is the simple concept that you put items
you will need in a container and when
you need them it already exists inside a
container let's understand this in a way
that is more related to coding let's
imagine our application have three pages
and in each page we will need three
functionalities we need to lock
something we need to send email and we
need to save something
our database so we will need to create
objects of these functions and classic
dates will be creating objects of email
database and logger in the first page
then we will do the same in the second
page and so on but this is different
with dependency injection let's take a
look at that with dependency injection
again we have the same three pages and
we want the same three functionalities
or the classes we have a dependency
injection container what we will do is
we will register all the three classes
inside our container whenever any page
will need anything we will directly
extracted from that container rather
than creating a new object in individual
pages it is created and registered in
the container we only have to use this
this way container deals with creating
registering and disposing of the objects
rather than creating them in every page
this is how efficient dependency
injection is compared to the classic
approach now that our project is created
in this section we will start building
all the functionalities in our project
we will first add the model that we want
to and push it to database after that we
will perform crud operations on book
list with that we will complete our
project with the reserved pages and you
will see how everything comes to picture
so let's get started with all of that
from the next video in this video we
will be installing our first NuGet
package so for that let me run the
application and show you why we need
that package so when you hit the Run
button it will load our website and you
can see the default layout that we have
we have a home page and a privacy page
let's go to our home raiser page and
edit this text so for that we'll switch
back to our application
and we'll go to solution exploded all of
the pages will be inside the pages
folder will be double click on index dot
CSS HTML and right here while the
application is running with an ad my
name broke in here save it go back and
refresh you can see the refresh was
successful but the content here did not
change this was an existing feature
before asp.net core 3 but with 3 they
have decided to add this Auto refresh
for the view as a separate package so
we'll stop the application we'll go to
tools NuGet package manager and manage
NuGet packages for solution inside the
Browse tab we will search for microsoft
asp net court MVC dot racer
dot runtime compilation we have to
install this package inside our book
list brazier project we'll accept this
and once the installation is complete we
need to make one change inside our
startup dot C S Class file and we have
the configure services method in here
where we have the dot add raiser pages
we will have dot add rizal runtime
compilation after you add this line if
you press f5 or hit the Run button here
it will load the website again and the
content will be welcome propane right
now let's see that perfect let's switch
back let's go back to our index and
remove Pro gain and let's refresh the
page and this time it should
automatically reload and it should
display welcome great you can see that
in action and with this whenever you
will change anything inside the Razr UI
and you come back here while the APNIC
is running and refresh this should
automatically refresh this is one of a
core package that is needed for
developers because we are many times
dealing with the view we make changes we
come back and we want to see the change
rather than restarting the application
in this video what we will do is we will
be adding our first model now models
represents any table that you want in
your database in this project what we
want to do is we want to manage a list
of books so for that we will add a model
or a table called book in order to do
that in our project we'll right click
add let's add a new folder to separate
things out and we'll call this model
inside here we'll right click add a new
class file and we'll call this book then
in here we will add a few properties
first will be the ID so we'll say crop
this will be an integer ID this will be
a unique key so we can add a data
annotation by typing key and if we do
control dot here you see using system
dot component model dot data annotation
what key will do is it will
automatically add ID as an identity
column so that way we do not have to
pass the value it will create an ID
value automatically along with ID we
also want name of the book so we'll do
prop string and name then we want the
author so we'll do prop again prop is a
snippet for property so if you type prop
and hit tab twice it will automatically
create a property will call this as
author and let's make it string now for
name I want to display book name so for
that we have a display attribute and we
also have a required data annotation
let's try the required first when we do
required this means that name
cannot be known the display data
annotation I will add it as we proceed
with the course so this looks good for
my book and these three properties
should be sufficient once we have
created this book next thing is to add
this to database for that we have to add
few packages for entity framework and we
have to set up connection string let's
do that in the next video now that we
have added book model inside our project
we need to set up the database in order
to set up the database we need few
packages so we'll go to tools NuGet
package manager and package manager
solution here the first package we want
is Microsoft entity framework or we'll
select this the version is 3.0 looks
good let's install this these are all
the entity framework packages that we
are needing because we'll be using
entity framework to access database
after this we need dot sequel server so
we'll search for that and we'll be using
sequel server so we'll add this package
as well and the final package that we'll
need is entity framework or dot tools
and this is required because we'll be
running migrations I will explain you in
the next video what exactly migrations
are so don't worry but these are the
three packages that you need if you
remove and close this your application
should have these four packages right
now okay so with this we have installed
all the necessary packages now we need
to set up our connection string let's go
to sequel server real quick and in here
when you try to connect you need a
server name the server name that you see
right here
local DB in bracket backward slash ms
sequel local DB this is the default
server name that sequel server has so
right here we'll use this in our
connection string so let me just go back
and the connection screen that will be
adding will be inside app setting start
JSON as I explained before so for
connection string right here before
logging let me just paste that this is
what you need to write it will be
connection strings with a plural s at
the end and we'll set up a default
connection you can give default
connection any other name that you want
then for the server we have the exact
server name that we see inside sequel
server make sure this is aligned and
also try to connect once you connect
this means that this server name is
valid after that you can use the same
server name here then for the database
we'll create a new database called
publish tracer make sure that you do not
create that database automatically from
sequel server we will be doing that
using visual studio so right now you see
we do not have published grazer database
here we'll go back we have the trusted
connection true and we have the multiple
active results adds to true I will be
pasting this exact string with the
lecture as well so that you don't have
to waste time to type this manually but
make sure the server name is valid with
what you have once the connection string
is an app setting start JSON next thing
we have to do is we have to configure
our startup class file and let's do the
configuration and run migrations in the
next video now that we have the
connection string inside app setting
start JSON it's time to configure our
configure services with entity framework
in order to configure that we need an
application DB context or a DB context
class so that plus we can add inside
solution Explorer model right-click add
a new class we'll call this class
application DB context let's add this
now the application DB contacts should
inherit from DB
context class which is a class inside
Microsoft entity framework or after this
we need to implement the constructor and
we have to pass the dbcontext options to
the parent class so for constructor we
have a snippet called ctor and we'll
press tab twice right here we have to
pass the dbcontext options and in here
we need the application dbcontext we'll
call this options this will have to pass
to the base and we'll pass the options
here this is an empty constructor but
the parameter is needed for dependency
injection once we have that then we need
to add the book model that we added to
our database in order to add any model
to the database inside the DB context
you need an entry we will do public and
this will be DB set of type book and
let's call this property to book as well
once you add this the last thing that
you have to do is add the dbcontext
inside startup dot CS so inside startup
dot CS we have to add the DB context to
our pipeline
so we'll say services dot add DB context
and right here we have to pass our class
name which is application dbcontext
we'll do a control dot here and we need
to pass the options with connection
string so we'll say options dot use
sequel server we'll have to do a control
dot here and the use sequel server we
added as a new get package in here we
need to pass the connection string from
our app settings dot JSON so for that we
can use the configuration object that we
have so we'll just say configuration dot
in here we have the get connection
string and we need to pass the name that
we used for our connection string which
is default connection we'll copy this
and we'll pass this in a
Turing notation like this so this was
the configuration that we had to do to
include entity framework inside the
configuration pipeline once you have
this all you have to do is you need to
push this to database so for that we'll
go to tools they will get package
manager this time we'll be going to
package manager console and in here the
project name it should be ProQuest racer
we'll type the command add migration and
we will add a meaningful name what we
are doing right now is add book to
database or dB
we'll press ENTER and what add migration
will do is it will create a script that
will be executed across the database the
script has been created right here you
see what the script is doing is it is
automatically creating a table called
book and it is adding the columns ID
name and author it is also making sure I
didna label is false and name the label
is false author nullable is true because
if we go we do not have any required
attribute with author since ID is a key
it knows that it is not nullable in the
constraint it is also adding primary key
or the table and in the annotation it is
making sure that ID is identity column
so this is the perfect script that is
needed to create the book table now
right now only script has been created
with the add migration command how do we
actually create the database and create
the table for that we have a command
called
update database once you hit update
database it will check if the database
exists if it does not it will create the
database and it will also push the
migrations once the update database
command completes successfully you can
go back to your sequel server and to the
database let's refresh it right now if
you expand
and go on tables you see we have the
book table that has been created and if
you do select top thousand you will see
the three columns perfect so with this
we created our database and we also
added the book table with the properties
that we wanted now the purpose of this
course is to perform crud operations on
this book object so for that we need
pages to create a new book edit a new
book delete a book and also view all of
the books that are available so we'll go
to solution explorer and inside pages we
have the index page and few other pages
all of the book pages let me add this in
a new folder and we'll call this book
list in here let me add a new razor page
so what you have to do is right click
add and we'll add the razor page we will
go with the empty razor page because
going with this will solve our problems
but we will not know what was done so
we'll go with the empty razor page and
let's call this index what are all the
options here first option is to create a
page model class as you saw with the
index page here we have index page as
well as page model we need a page model
class because we need to populate all of
the books from the database and pass
that to the page to displayed so that's
why we'll need that then this won't be a
partial view a partial view is something
which is a small subsection like maybe
group of buttons that you want to reuse
in multiple places in your website but
this is a complete page so that won't be
a partial view and we will use our
layout page because that is the master
page and we want to be consistent so
with this let's add this one drawback
that I see with the razor pages is when
we will be adding index pages it might
get confusing because you see we have a
man
index page inside book list we have
another index page so whenever you are
working make sure you are working on the
correct index page at this time we'll be
working on index and index page model
inside the book list so if you have any
other pages open you can close them
inside the index page what we want to do
is we want to retrieve all of the books
from the database so for that we need
the application dbcontext whenever you
have to deal with the database you will
need the application dbcontext
when you add it the application
dbcontext right here in the services
that means that you have added it to the
pipeline once you have added it as a
pipeline you can use them using
dependency injection so we need an
object of application dbcontext what you
will do is use a private read-only
application dbcontext
and let's call this underscore DB now we
need to initiate our constructor so
we'll type CT or our tab tab and right
here
we will get the application DB contacts
DB this application DB context we are
getting using dependency injection so
right here will say underscore DB is
equal to DB this way you can extract the
application DB context that is inside
the dependency injection container and
inject it on to this page if you did not
have dependency injection what you would
have to do is you would have to create a
new object and then once you are done
with that you'll have to dispose that
and all the other things with dependency
injection you do not have to bring out
anything now what we want to do is we
want to return a list or an ienumerable
of book so we'll say public eye in iam
rebel of book let's call this books will
have the getter
and setter what people do is we'll
assign this books all of the books from
the database how do we get that it's
very simple because we're using entity
framework we'll use a weight here and
we'll say underscore DB dot books you
can see it already has the book and we
have a method here which is to list and
we'll call the async method we'll have
to do a control dot for the easing to
use entity framework or now when you are
using async and await rather than void
you will have to use async task what we
are doing here is we are going to
database and retrieving all of the books
storing that inside the ienumerable and
we are doing that inside the get handler
so when we go inside the view here we
will already have the list of books
available to display all you did was
right here you extracted that and it is
already available inside your view to
display now one thing to notice is right
now I'm using a weight and async
what async does this is a basic c-sharp
explanation and not related to dotnet
core so I won't be going into much
details but async will basically let you
run multiple tasks at a time until it is
awaited right here's we need to awake
because we need to assign all the books
that we found but the method that we
have is also acing and tasks so this was
all you had to do for the get handler
again if it was MVC this would be action
methods but with razor pages inside the
page model we have handlers in the next
video let's write some code here and see
the list of books now that we have added
the cat handler method for the index
page inside book list it's time to add
some uie here the first thing we'll do
is we'll go to solution Explorer and
we'll go to our master page which is
underscored
we have home and privacy let me add a
book tab in place of privacy and for
that we have to change the ASP page so
for that rather than privacy we will
have polished /index and if you save
this that's run our application once you
click on this it should load the index
page in order to see the difference you
have to go here and let me type index
book save this and let's click on the
book for a fact you can see the page is
loaded so with this you can see inside
underscore layout how you had to
manipulate the routing for the ASP page
tag helpers if you want to access
something inside the book list you have
to write the Polish name followed by the
page that we have which is the index
page then we can keep this application
running we can go to index and we'll
design this so we'll just remove this
let me add Br
then let me just remove this index and
we'll start designing this page we also
do not need the view data we can remove
that we let a be R and we let a div give
it a class of container these are the
bootstrap classes Rho padding:0 and
margin:0 within this first container
I'll add a div give it a class of column
10 and I'll also add another div give it
a class of column 2 if you are not
familiar with bootstrap bootstrap
divides a row into 12 equal columns so
that's why I'm dividing 1 column inside
two separate columns first will occupy
10 columns and the next one will be the
rest two columns inside here I'll use
edge to give it a bootstrap class of
text info for a bluish color and will
display book list in here we will add an
anchor tag and we'll give it a class of
BTN BTN in
and form control these are all bootstrap
classes and we'll say create new book
let's save this let's go back and
refresh the page
we're factus is coming along good let me
increase the size here so we can do
column three and we'll have to make it
column nine perfect this is good we'll
just make it text white here so right
here we can do text white okay this
looks good now what we want to do is we
want to display a table with all of the
books let's continue working on the
designing in the next video
let's continue working on the designing
right now we have to create new book but
when we click nothing happens and that
is because we have not used any tag
helpers on where it should redirect
we'll do that in a while after this
column 9 and column 3 let me add another
div give it a class of column 12 we'll
give it a border padding 3 and marching
top of 3 or bootstrap classes and we'll
add a form here give it a method of post
within this form we want to display this
only if books exist inside the table so
we can use razor syntax here like
if-else condition for that you need add
sign and then you can use these sharp
syntax like if and we want to check if
there are any books that are returned
from this get method you can see inside
the page model we have the ienumerable
as book so inside the razor page you can
say model with a capital m dot right
here you can see books is available this
is the same books that is being passed
from the get handler right here so we
can check if model books count if this
is greater than 0 then we will display a
table else we will display a paragraph
and say notebooks available let's save
this let's go back and refresh and we
should see no books available now in
order to see some books right now we do
not have the create book page so let's
go to database and hack some things
we'll right-click on the book at the top
hundred so that window 1 1 and any of
the dummy record will come back here and
we'll refresh and that message is gone
and that is because it retrieved 1 book
that we just added so how do we display
that right here we will have to add a
table inside the if condition so we'll
add table give it bootstrap classes of
tabled table striped and border within
here we'll add a TR give it a class of
tables secondary and regularity H for
the table heading the end we will use
the label tag helper and the tag helper
we have is ASB for we will go to our
books and in here we want the first or
default because the label we want for
only one record and we'll say dot name
so this is how you can use tag helper
you can also use HTML helper for the
same thing let me show you that for the
author so the syntax for HTML helper was
pretty weird
so it was HTML dot display name for and
in here you will have to use the lambda
expression M goes to m dot books dot
first or default dot author now you can
see how tag helpers have made this
extremely simple it is the existing
label tag all you did was add ASP for so
that's why tag helpers are preferred
over HTML helpers but HTML helpers are
still there for some functionalities
which you have to write custom tag
helpers for and I will show you that in
just a while once you have the
let me add a th here and I will comment
this code out but I will leave there for
reference I'll copy this and paste it
here for author so this was the table
header we will add an empty th tag after
this we want all of the records so for
that we need a for each loop how do we
get for each loop inside the view again
the answer is at sign and then we have
the for each which is a c-sharp syntax
will say variable item in model with the
capital m dot books so for all of the
books that we have we will have item and
we will display a table row here so we
will add a TR tag and inside the TD we
want to display the value now in this
case we do not have a tag helper but we
have an HTML helper the HTML helper is
HTML dot display for in here we'll have
to use link M goes to item dot we want
to display the name we do not have an
equivalent dial per for display for of
course you can write a custom tag helper
that can do the exact same thing but
that is beyond the scope for this
project so we can just use the HTML
helper we can copy this and we'll paste
it again for author let me save this
let's go back and refresh and we should
see our record perfect this was so easy
now this is not aligned so we can do
control a control KD to align everything
that we have last thing that I want is
in here I want buttons to edit or delete
a book so after this TD and we've had
another TD and I will give button give
it a class give it a class of PT and BTN
danger and et and small these are all
bootstrap classes
and I will display delete after the
delete button we need a link to redirect
to the edit page so for that we'll use
the anchor tag and we'll give it a class
of BTN ET and success and we'll do PT
and small here this will be added let me
save this and refresh and great this is
good we will not worry about designing
much things here but this looks good and
delete I'll just do text white so that
it is aligned with the delete so with
this we have almost completed the index
page but we will come back here later
now the last thing that I want to do on
index page for this video is on create
book I want to add a link so that it
redirects me to a create raiser page so
for that right here inside the create
new book you will need a tag helper the
tag helper we have seen before in
underscored layout it is a SP page what
page do we want to redirect to that will
be a create page now you do not have to
mention here that the create page will
be inside book list because if you are
in the same folder you can directly
write the page name that being said
let's add the create page in the next
video in this video we will be adding
the create raiser page so let me stop
the application we'll go to solution
Explorer inside the book list we'll
right click add a razor page again it
will be the basic one and we'll say
create here it won't be a partial view
let's add this now with the create page
when the page will be loaded do we want
to display any data no we just want to
display text box so user can enter a
book name and an author so for that
right here we will again need the
application dbcontext not for the get
handler but when we hit the create
we need to save it to our database so we
will just do that while we are here
so we'll say private read-only
application dbcontext we'll do a control
dot to pad model and will have
underscore DB we need constructor so see
to your bar tab tab we'll get the
application they'll be contacts DB and
underscore TB is equal to DB now inside
the get method we need to display text
boxes to write the author name and the
book name what will be the model so that
will be public book let me call that
book will have the getter and setter on
get we do not have to write that we'll
be passing this empty book object it
does that automatically so inside the
create view you will be able to access
this book and display labels as well as
text boxes before we do that in the next
video
many times it's a common situation that
you start with a model and then you feel
no I need one more property or they're
like whoops I need to rename this so for
that what we will do is right here let's
imagine we have to add a new property
called ISBN so we'll write the new
property is B N and let's have a getter
and setter once you add a property since
you change something in the model here
you have to add a new migration so we'll
go to tools NuGet package manager
package manager console we'll write add
migration add ISBN to book model always
try to name your migration as meaningful
as possible perfect you can see it is
adding a new column and all you do is
update database so this way inside your
table a new column will be added if you
go back now and if you do select op
thousand you can see ISBN has been
added which is no this looks great and
now we know how we can make changes to a
model that we have already added we'll
have to change our index for the same
I'll just copy this and paste it one
more time I'll remove the display for
here we'll have the ISBN and we'll do
the same for HTML helper perfect so
these are all the changes that were
needed in the next video let's design
the create page and see everything in
action in this video we will start
designing the create raiser page we will
remove all of these things we'll add a
br we'll give it a heading here give it
a class of text info and let me just
play create new book followed by a br
now let me just paste some Bush wrap
styling that we have I'll align this all
I did was I added a div give it a class
of border and container and some styles
with padding then I added a form and in
that form
I have a div with class of form group
and row and inside that row I have
divided this into two parts call them
two and column six let me make it column
four and column six that should be okay
even though the total should add up to
12 you can leave it like this once you
have the same designing what we will do
is within the form we will add a method
of post because when we hit the create
button we will be posting data back to
our page handler within the column four
we want to display label so we'll do
label and ASP for this will be for book
dot we have the name after that we have
column six here we want a text box so
we'll say input we'll use the tag helper
ASP for this is for book dot name
and we'll give it a class of form
control you can see how easy the binding
is with the tag helpers you do not need
to worry about anything in the post book
dot name will have the value that user
enters inside this textbox so let me
just copy this and paste this two more
times
we have author and we have ISBN after
author and ISBN we will add another div
give it a class of form group and row
just like we did before
and we'll add a div give it a class of
column three offset of two let me do
column six offset of four that's what we
have and we'll add a div give it a class
of column 4 this should be column three
and this will be column three this is
because the six that we have we are
dividing that into two columns again the
first one will be an input and this will
be type of submit for the button and
will give it a value of create give it
some bullsh drop classes of BTN BTN
primary and form control the other one
is to go back to the index page so we'll
use the anchor tag and the tag helper
ASB page will take us back to the index
page and the classes will be BT and BT
and success and form control will
display back to list let me save this
and run our project we'll go to our book
and this time we'll hit create in your
book great you can see how good the page
is coming along if you think the size is
too big here you can always modify that
I'll change this to three in all the
places and that way it will be more
closer offset will also be three let's
save this and perfect looks much better
now if you click on back to list it
works and on create we need to work on
what will happen when we hit the submit
button right now if you do that nothing
happens and that is because inside the
create page model we do not have a post
handler so let's see how we can add a
post handler so that whenever they
submit anything from the page how do we
get the data and save that inside our
database
in this video we need to make sure when
we fill all of this information and hit
the create button it takes us back to
the page but before that we need some
validation as you know name was a
required property so if you hit create
before pressing the name we want to see
the error message right here we'll do
all of that let's stop the application
and let's go to the page model right
here we have the on cat handler but when
we hit the submit button we will be
posting data so for that we need a post
handler to retrieve that so we'll create
public async and task this task will be
of I action result because we'll be
redirecting to a new page and the
handler name will always start with on
and what is the handler name we want a
post handler so it will be on post when
this will be posted what will be passed
from this razor page we will be passing
a book object so far that will retrieve
a book object and we'll call this book
obj now rather than getting a book
object like this we already have a book
right here we can use the exact same
property rather than writing disc
asp.net core team has given a property
binding here where you have to write
bind property once you bind the property
it is automatically assumed that on the
post you will be getting this book right
here so that me all you have to do is
right here you can check if model state
dot is valid then proceed further else
if it is invalid we want to return back
to the page I'll explain you what mortal
state is but hang with me right now if
the model state is valid we want to type
the book to database adding that is
really simple we can use the underscore
dB in here we have the book and we have
an add a sink right here what is the
parameter we want to add the book which
is to await here and this will work
after we add the book we need to save
changes to the database right now this
book has not been added to the database
it is just added to a queue which will
be eventually pushed to the database
when we type the command underscore DB
don't Save Changes they synchronously
only when this command is executed then
the data will be pushed to the database
and once the changes are pushed to the
database all that is remaining is
returned we will redirect to a page and
that page will be the index page this
looks scared let's run our application
and see this in action so we'll go to
book we will try to create a new book
and let's hit the create button great
you can see the book has been created
now let's try to create a new book and
hit the create button you see nothing
happens if you type name here and hit
create it gets created but if you try it
without name it won't be created and
that is because name is a required
property what is actually happening is
if we add a debugger here and if we go
back and try to hit the create button
the control goes back here
and let me add few more debuggers hit
continue the model state if you hover is
invalid what is not valid if you go on
model state you will have to go to
result view and right here you will see
the name is invalid and the reason it is
invalid is it is a required property and
you are not passing any value but we
need some error messages to see that it
is actually
an adder in order to do that let me hit
continue and we go back inside the view
here we need to add a div we'll add a
div give it a class of text danger this
will be a red color and that is a
special tag helper JSP validation
summary we'll change this to model only
once we have this what we need is we
want to display individual adder so
we'll add span here and we have a SP
validation for tag helper here we want
the validation for book dot name we'll
give it a class of text danger we can
copy this we'll do the same for author
and ISBN once you do this if you save
this go back and refresh the page the
control comes back here
let's hit the continue whoops I think
there are some changes we'll just stop
this remove the debugger now and let's
just run the application again this time
if we go to book and if we try to create
a new book hit the create button you can
see the error message comes right up I
need to show one more thing here let me
show you that in the next video
now we see the added message
but there is one more issue if you go
back to the application while it's
running let's add a debugger here in the
model state and hit the create button
again you can see that the control is
going to the on post handler it finds
the model state is invalid and it
returns back with the error we want this
to be done on the client side in order
to do that if we switch back we go to
create right here inside solution
Explorer
we have the validation scripts partial
all we have to do is we
their reference so right here we'll do
ad section this will be scripts and
right here we will use partial tag
helper name we will paste the name this
name will be exactly same as validation
scripts partial make sure that is no
spelling mistake we'll save this let's
go back go back to the home page let me
do ctrl f5 for hard refresh let's try to
create again and let's make it empty
take the create button you see the error
message pops up it doesn't go back and
to confirm if we go back we still have
our debugger so this means the
validation here is done on the client
side without posting back so that way we
have both the validation server side as
well as client side so this was one way
I wanted to show you that the validation
should be done both client side as well
as server side now the create is
completed in the next video let's start
working on the Edit functionality now we
will be working on the edit raiser page
so while this is running if we can go
back and we go to our index if we scroll
down where we have the Edit in here we
need to pass the routing so the ASP page
this will be the padded page which we
will create now whenever an user clicks
on the edit button we want to pass the
ID of the field that they are editing in
this case it will be ID of the book so
in order to pass that we have another
tag helper and that is ASV we have route
and then we need to define the name that
we want we can just call this as ID what
we want to pass here is the actual ID of
the book which is inside at item dot ID
this way when a user clicks on edit it
go to the Edit racer page and it will
also pass ID as the parameter let me
save this let me stop this let's go back
inside the pages book list
let's add a new razor page called as
edit perfect in the get handler we will
get a parameter of ID that we just pass
it will be an integer based on this
integer we will retrieve the book we can
use find property and we can start first
with private application dbcontext
because we will have to update things we
will to see to your our constructor will
have the application DB contacts DB
underscore DB is equal to DB great then
we need to bind property in here we'll
be working with just one book so will
the public book let's call this book
will have the catcher and setter here we
need to populate this book object based
on the database with the ID that we
received so a weight will do underscore
t be dark book not find a sync and here
we just need to pass the ID this is
another method that we have with our
entity framework rather than wild this
will be async and task because we are
using a weight here this looks good for
our get method in the next video let's
design the Edit view and continue
working on posting or editing a book now
we will be working on editing the book
UI the UI will look similar to what we
have for create but the only difference
will be the data will be loaded so we
can go to create dot C as HTML and we
can copy everything right here do not
copy the model because model
we'll be different so right here will
remove everything and we'll paste what
we just copied rather than create new
book it will be edit book then if you
scroll down we have submit here the
value will be update and indexed this
looks good let's run our application and
see the edit page here we'll go to book
and we'll hit the edit button great you
can see the data is loaded it's added
book and we have the update button if
you try to hit update nothing happens
because we have not added the post
handler also in the URL you see the ID
is being passed and this is the ASP
route ID that we added so everything is
coming along good in the next video
let's work on the post handler and this
video will be working on the update
button if we close this here
inside the Edit you see the form method
is post and we have the input type
submit so on post we need to write a
post handler in post handler will be
redirecting to page so that's why the
return type will change that to I action
result so task of I action result and
we'll call this on post
the first thing we'll check here is if
model state is valid if this is valid
then we will proceed further and we'll
retrieve the book from the database
because we have to edit this now
updating can be done in multiple ways so
one of the way is we retrieve that from
DB is equal to we'll say await
underscore DB book dot find a sync and
we'll pass the book oops book dot ID we
have the book object right here we'll
retrieve it and pass the ID
and will say book from DB dot name is
equal to book name we can just copy this
and paste this two more times for ISBN
and author will copy the same here
perfect once we change this we will say
await under Scotty B dot Save Changes
asynchronous and this will update the
book object inside the database once we
update this will return redirect to page
and we want to redirect to the index
page if the model state is not valid we
will return and redirect back to page
now let's see this in action and when we
try to run this we'll hit into an error
I want to show you that error message
before I show you the solution we go to
book here let's try to edit this and
we'll change the ISBN to three three
three great we see an error message here
that object reference is not set to an
instance of an object this is a common
error message and it is not self
explanatory it just says that the object
it was expecting value but it is a null
value now we have to debug on what's
going on so we'll add a debugger inside
the model state variable and right here
let's go back and we'll go back here and
hit the Update button okay we'll see the
model state is valid let's continue
we'll see the book object and you see
the ID is not present we have all the
other values the ISBN is the updated one
but the ID is missing and the reason
behind that is if we had continue here
let me remove the debuggers head
continue again we'll get the error
that's okay
inside the edit we do not have the ID
here
we have name right here author and ISBN
we need the ID property inside a hidden
field so we'll 2 input type is equal to
hidden and we need the ASP for tag
helper for the ID so it will be book dot
ID once you have it and save it and if
you go back let's go back here and let's
do a hard refresh and update the value
this time it is updated because it finds
the ID now so always make sure that
inside edit and such fields you have the
ID or any other properties that you want
while updating must be present in the
hidden property if you do not have that
inside the input text box also if you go
on edit we already have our validations
so if you try to update it gives the
error message so with this we have
completed create and edit let's work on
delete in this video we'll be
implementing the delete now with delete
you can do it the same way we did for
edit and create you can create a new
view where you will display the details
and on the delete button you can do a
post event but I want to try something
new here this time when we hit delete I
want to show an alert and when the user
clicks ok I want to delete it directly
from the index page so for that let's
implement the pop-up first we'll go back
I'll close edit create and we have the
index right here we have the delete
button I will add an on click method
here and we will save return will have a
confirm box you sure you want to delete
if this returns true we want to go to a
page handler on the same index page so
we'll do a SP page
and we'll have a handler we have not
used this tag helper before this time we
want to implement a custom tag helper
other than the on gate and on post we
want to call this as delete and when
we'll be deleting we need to pass the ID
of the book we already know how to pass
it using ASP route we'll call it ID and
we'll pass item ID let's save this let's
go back and refresh and when we hit the
delete we now see an alert here on
cancel nothing happens
what should happen when they click OK we
have to implement a delete Handler
inside the index page
so instead solution Explorer will open
the page model let me stop it here and
we will implement public async task of
I'll action result because we'll be
redirecting to the same page and we'll
implement on post delete will have an
integer of ID that we will fetch because
on the index we have the ID this is a
button so that's why it will be a post
handler so we will have the on post and
then the handler name which we have
defined as delete ok so what we want to
do in here we'll say variable book is
equal to we can do it in multiple ways
first we can find the book
so we'll do a weight underscore TV book
dot find a sync and we'll pass the ID
then we'll check if book is equal to now
that means that book does not exist
based on the ID that is passed and will
return not found if we find the book
will say underscore TV dot dot dot
remove in here we'll pass the book that
we retrieved and we need to save the
changes so await underscore t b dot save
changes async
once we remove the book will return back
to the page or we can return back to the
index page making it reload let's save
this and let's run our application we'll
go to book let's try to delete this 1 1
1 and perfect
you can see our delete functionality is
working as expected so with this we have
completed the crud operations on book
list using result syntax now we have
implemented the current functionalities
that we seen before these crud
functionalities are basic HTML and
dotnet core how about we add some
styling and some data tables to that so
for that I'll be needing three things
first will be sweet alert because of
which we'll be having such nice alerts
then we have toasters for notifications
like this and we'll be using data tables
to list all the books in such a
fashionable way that our CD ends that
are needed for that what I will do is I
will have a file attached with the CSS
and the JavaScript so you can just copy
this go back to your code we'll stop it
we'll have to go to underscored layout
on top we have the CSS we'll paste it
here for data tables jQuery UI and
toaster and we'll also copy the jas and
we'll scroll down to the java scripts
and we'll paste it right here now with
data tables we need to add API calls to
retrieve all of the books in a JSON
format and we'll also add an API call
for delete in order to add API calls we
need to add Web API to our project right
now it's only Razer so for that we'll
right click add a new folder let's call
those controllers I'll make it plural
controllers will right click add a new
controller in here we can go with the
MVC controller or the API controller
anyone is fine we'll just go with the
MVC controller and we'll call this book
controller inside the book controller we
will need that application dbcontext so
right here
we'll have private read-only application
dbcontext will to a control dot
underscore DB will have the constructor
application DB contacts DB and
underscore DP is equal to DB then we
need to implement the HTTP GET and HTTP
delete let's just implement the HTTP GET
we'll change this to get all and with
the cat it should be HTTP kept what we
want to do is we want to return a JSON
here and we'll say new we want to pass
data is equal to underscore TB dot dot
dot to list so that way we'll retrieve
the book and we'll pass it back when you
call this API call
but api's are not supported inside our
startup right now what we have right now
is only a dresser pages so in order to
do that we'll do services dot add
controller with views once you add this
you'll be adding the API calls we will
also have to add that to our middleware
especially inside the endpoints so we'll
use endpoints dot map controllers this
way the controller api's will be called
and right here we need to define the
route that should be used to call this
so the route we'll just call it API
forward slash book and this will be an
API controller so that we will make sure
that the book controller is an API
controller and
is the route that will be used in such
start-up since we have added map
controller you can navigate to this URL
and get requests will return you data
from here and this wheel you will be
making changes to the index page that is
inside pages book list index and right
here we have the first day of that we
are using right now I will add another
div here let me just paste it and all we
are doing here is column 12 we have an
or and I have a div with column 12 I
have a table with ID of DT load this is
important and I am just displaying the
table headers I think I have an extra
div here there we go
now how do we load this table that table
will be loaded using javascript so for
that we will add a section here and it
will be scripts we will have the script
tag here will give us our see inside GS
I will create a new java script called
book list GS let's add that script file
inside the WW root GS will add a new
item we can search for Java here and
let's call this book list and then let's
start working on the Java Script here so
we'll have the variable data table here
and he'll use the dollar document dark
ready function we'll add a function in
here and we'll call load data table
let's add this load data table so we can
just copy this and we'll add a function
here paste that and what we want to do
here is will bloat the variable data
table we want to load it on index we
have the DT load we can copy this well
brief that hash and DT load dot we will
call data table this data table has been
included with the JavaScript reference
that you added with data tables so dot
data table will populate a data table on
DT load in here we have few things we
need to make an AJAX call to our API so
for that right here we need to define
the URL and URL is forward slash API
forward slash look then we need a type
here because this will be a get request
followed by data type and data type will
be JSON after the ajax call we need to
define all the columns that we have to
display so right here we will have
columns and this will be an array so
right here the first one will do data
and what is the name of the column that
is name itself comma we want to say what
width it should occupy so that will be
in percentage so we can do 30 percent we
can copy this and paste it two more time
we have author here and we have ISBN
make sure it follows camel casing
if inside book the variable you had is
name right here you had named ABC then
what you would do is right here this
will be named ABC the first one shall be
a lower case we only have name so
everything is the lower case right here
after this the last column we want is
edit and delete buttons so in the last
one the data field that we want is the
ID because when we edit or delete we
need to pass the ID of the book so we'll
have ID here and we will have a render
because we want to
two buttons here so this will be a
function and we will pass the ID so
that's why we'll pass the data which has
the ID in here what we want to do is we
want to return a div with two buttons
since this will be a multi-line
statement we can use the till sign and
break up the statements till sign is
available right next to the one on your
keyboard here we start with div give it
a class of text Center and we'll add
ending div since there is no
intelligence you have to do this
manually then you have an anchor tag we
will do H ref what we want to do is we
want to add an edit page and right here
we will have book lurched forward slash
edit and we need to pass the ID so ID is
equal to dollar and in here we have the
data so that way we'll be passing the
data which has the ID of the book we'll
give it a classes of BT and BT and
success and text white we will also give
it a style of cursor of pointer and
we'll give it a width of 100 pixels this
looks good for our anchor tag and then
in the next line we will add the edit
button we will close the anchor tag here
and we can copy this anchor tag because
we want another one for delete so right
here I'll add some space ampersand and
bsp and we'll paste it one more time on
delete we do not want to go to any of
the URL so we'll leave the extra out
right now we'll have the classes of
beauty and danger and we'll add an
onclick but we'll do that later I just
make it delete and we'll have the
closing div so this looks good
then in this render we will add width
here and we'll make it
30% outside of this array that we had
four columns will do , and I will add
language here in here
I do empty tables if there is no data I
want to display no data found we'll do a
comma here and we'll give it a width of
100% everything should be in double
quotes like this so with this we have
our data table in place let me save this
and we need to run our application to
see this in action we already added the
code inside the index page so if we go
on book we will see two tables now the
first one you can see right here and
here is the later one but here the Java
Script is not getting called and I guess
that's because we have a mistake with
the file name here it should be book
list JavaScript let's enter that and hit
the Run button again we go one book and
great we see our data table in place
with the number of entries we have
pagination sorting and search by default
here the stylings has not been applied
let me go back and take a look
we forgot and equal to here let's save
this go back and refresh and perfect we
see everything is coming along
let me just reduce the size here I'll
make it 20 and we can make this 40 and
width let me make it 70 pixels and both
the places let's save it and refresh and
perfect this looks much aligned when you
hit the edit it will take you to the
edit page and if you click on delete
right now nothing happens
in this video let's work on the delete
on delete we want to display a nice
alert here and on okay we want to delete
it directly but using an API call so for
that we'll have to go back and we'll
have to add an API call inside our book
controller so we will add an HTTP delete
here and this will be public I action
result delete here we'll be getting an
ID that we have to delete we'll say
variable book from DB is equal to
underscore DB pub dark first our default
and we can say here goes to you dot ID
is equal equal to ID now right here it
is always good to be consistent so we're
going to async and it will be task of I
action result and we will do await here
and we have the two lists async we'll
have to do a control dot to include
entity framework or first our default we
have the async method in here so we'll
do control dot oops there we go and
we'll use a weight we have async task of
I action result then we'll check here if
the book from DB is equal equal to mount
in this case we will return JSON and
we'll return nil this time we want to
make sure success is false because we
did not receive any book comma will also
display a message error while deleting
if we found that book with an underscore
DB dot dot dot remove and we'll say a
weight underscore DB dot Save Changes
asynchronous
then we will return back the JSON this
time we'll have a new and success will
be true and we'll have a message which
will be delete successful so this looks
good
here we are getting an error let's do a
control dot whoops and that is because
we did not pass the object that we had
to remove we just booked from DB perfect
so the delete method looks good all we
have to do is inside the JavaScript we
need to add a function to delete let's
do that in the next video in this video
we'll be adding a function to delete and
call our API so right here where we have
the delete tag we will add an on click
method so right here we will say on
click is equal to let's call the
function delete and we'll pass our API
call here so we'll have API book and
then we need to pass the ID is equal to
we'll do plus and we have the dollar
data and then at the end we will be
adding the delete function so we'll add
function delete will receive the URL
here and we need to display sweet alert
so we'll to SW al and we'll add the
properties like title are you sure
comma we will have text once deleted you
will not be able to recover we can have
an icon here of warning and we can have
a danger mode here to true these are
just some of the properties that you can
use and we'll be using Ajax here so
we'll use 10 and in here
will delete this will be the response
based on this will have a function here
we'll check if we'll delete that means
if user selected yes they want to delete
we will make an AJAX call here a checks
call will have the type of delete we
will have the URL which we have right
here inside the parameters we'll do a
comma on success what we want to do is
we want a function with data that we
retrieved and we want to display a
toaster notification so we will do
toaster dot we have this success here
and we want to display message inside
here I need an if condition and we'll
check if this is success or not if this
is successful we'll display
toaster dot message and we will say data
table this should be message and that is
because if we go to controller we have
message right here and then we'll do
data table dot Ajax dot reload in the
else block here we want to display an
adder so I can copy this and paste it
and this will be a derp
this looks good we'll add the two
semicolon and now let's run our
application we'll go to book let's try
to delete great we see the notification
here you can click outside or you can
hit the delete and if we hit delete here
it doesn't do anything but actually if
you refresh the data is deleted we have
some issues with the display so right
here let's see the toaster this should
not be message it should be data dot
message because we have that inside the
object and also if you go to book
controller I have a mistake with success
spelling here let's run it and see
everything in action let's go to book
and create new book let's hit the delete
ok great we see a nice toaster
notification and then if we just scroll
back inside the suite alert I will add
another property here buttons is equal
to true and after that if we go back and
we go to book create new let's add one
create and then if we click delete we
see ok and cancel so that way we have
everything working now here I have had
requests from student many times that
the create view will look similar to
what we have for our edit so why not
combine both of them in one view or one
razor page so that can be done
absolutely let me stop the application
and I'll show you how that is possible
usually the name for such page is absurd
because it is a combination of update
and insert so we can just copy the edit
that we have or let me just add a new
view because when we copy we have to
make sure many things needs to be
updated like model so the page name it
will be absurd and this looks good let's
add that inside our book list it will be
similar to edit page but there will be
modifications
let's first copy everything that we have
inside edit not the model so we'll copy
this and we'll close that will go to our
absurd page and we'll paste it right
here let's save this let's go to the
edit page model and we'll copy
everything inside the model from
application dbcontext and we'll just
leave two brackets at the end
whoops which start after the two
brackets and there we go let's copy this
lets close this go to the absurd and
let's remove this and paste it right
here now what will happen with an absurd
is it will be used for creating as well
as updating will do control dot here
because of which inside the edit model
this will be absurd model actually and
because of which the I D it is possible
there won't be any ID if this is used
for create so that's why we have to use
a nullable integer so that ID can be
null then inside the get what we have to
do is we'll say book is equal to new
book once we have that we'll check here
if ID is equal to now if ID is null that
means that this is for create so we will
return back to the page if that is not
known we will continue here because of
this we need to change from task to I
action result if the ID is not note that
means we have to retrieve the book from
the database so book is equal to
underscore DB book dot first our default
async will have to do control dot to
include entity framework or we'll do a
weight here and we'll say you goes to
you dot ID is equal equal to the ID we
will find the book and after we find
this will check if and we'll say book is
equal equal to null if that is true then
we'll return not found if this is not
the case we will return back to the page
now when we are retrieving from the
database you can use first or default
async or you can use find async any of
those methods would work so this way we
will handle it for both create this will
be for create
and with this will be for update so the
same handler will be using for both the
scenarios that looks good for the get
handler then inside the post handler we
will do the same
we will check first if the model state
is valid or not if it's not valid
we'll return back then if it is valid
what we will do is right here we'll
check if book dot ID is equal equal to
zero if this is true then underscore DB
book dot ad and with AD book else what
we will do is underscore DB
book dot we also have update method in
here we'll pass the book so previously
you saw other way of updating the book
by retrieving it from the database and
here we're using directly the update
method so when should you use the
previous one versus this one this update
should be used if you want to update
every property of the book but if you
only want to update two properties we
will use the way that we used inside the
edit page once we do this we'll save the
changes and we'll redirect back to the
page so perfect this looks good for our
observe get as well as post handlers in
the next video let's fix the update view
or the waser page and we should be good
in the last video we fix the handlers
for absurd in this video let's work on
the result page the things that we have
to do differently and create an edit is
the title here so in here we can use the
razor syntax and we can check if model
book ID does not equal to zero if this
is true we will display edit else we
will display create we will copy this
condition and we will have to do the
same for the ID in the hidden property
we'll add F model dot dot dot I D does
not equal to zero then we will have the
ID else we do not need it in the create
largely if you scroll down we need to do
the same for the button so inside the
input type we can just replace this with
button we can say type is equal to
submit and we can add the same classes
BTN BTN primary form control and we'll
paste what we had before for ad model so
if this is not not then we will display
as update else we will display create
let's save this and with this the absurd
view or the razor page looks good how do
we test this we can go to our booklet J
s and if we scroll up so we'll change
this to absurd here and we'll also
change the create so far that will have
to go to the index and then if we scroll
up
right here we'll change this to absurd
let's save this and run our application
and right here we'll go to book and hit
create new book we are on the absurd
let's try to create one book great this
world and if we click on the edit here
it takes us to the absurd
let's try to update this for a fact that
is working if we click on edit in the
first one it takes you to the edit page
here we can also add a new text box so
that we'll have both of them so I can
just copy this and paste it one more
time next will be create and create new
book add absurd whoops
I think I switched that around let me
paste this will save this go back and
refresh I have one more thing I'll have
to change this to six and perfect now we
see create new book takes us to create
add absurd
takes you to the absurd but everything
is exactly the same so with this we
complete the absurd and how you can
combine both of the logic inside a
single razor page now that we have
completed result object it's time to
explore the other type of application
which is an MVC project so in this
section we'll create our next project
which will be the book list but in that
we will use every scene we will take a
look at how routing is different in MVC
as compared to razor pages and we'll see
the new folders with the MVC project so
let's get started with that from the
next video what we have to do is we need
to create project for our MVC crud
operation which dot Visual Studio 2019
and we'll select create a new project
in here we'll select asp.net core web
application and hit the next button then
we need a name of our project so we'll
call it vocalist MVC and you'll select a
location I'll change the location to
what I want and I hit the create button
that being said we need to select
options for our project now in here
we'll select asp.net core 3.1 and we'll
be selecting MVC for our project we can
change the authentication to select
individual users account but with that
many things comes configured so I do not
want to start with that route we'll go
with no authentication and we'll add
database objects manually that way we
will learn those concepts that being
said once everything is aligned here
let's hit the create button for effects
over this the project has been created
with model views and controller and this
is slightly different to what we have
seen with Razer pages as we saw from the
architecture we will have controllers
which will have the logic models we'll
have the data and view will be the UI
component so we have all of those three
folders right here and the other things
are common like www dependencies
properties app settings program Garcias
and startup Darcy s the only difference
is inside startup dot C S Class file if
you scroll down inside configure
services we do not have the add raiser
pages we have add controllers with views
also if you scroll down route here and
set the routing and endpoints they have
registered map controller route because
we need controller actions and even
areas in advanced courses so these are
the only differences between MVC and
racer pages inside the setup files of
course the working of control
models and views is completely different
and we'll understand that in the
upcoming videos in this video let's take
a look at the folder structure in an MVC
project the three main folders that are
different are model views and controller
right here the first folder is the
controllers folder and in here we have
the main logic of our web application
here we have the home controller one
rule that we have is the controller name
will be home and it should match exactly
with the folder inside the view so if we
have the views for home page the
controller name will be home followed by
a controller keyword inside the home
controller you can see we have methods
here and all of these methods are called
actions so the terminology to remember
is within controller we will have
actions the next folder that we have is
the models folder here as of now we only
have error view model but as we proceed
we will be adding new models here any
table that we have in a database we will
have a corresponding class as a model in
this folder we will also have view
models which are the combination of
multiple models and we will discuss them
in detail when we need them finally we
have the views folder in here if we
expand we have the shared folder in
which we have the underscored layout and
validation scripts partial which we
discussed and we have view imports and
view start the new folder is the home
folder and in here we have index and
privacy and one thing to notice is
inside the home controller we have
actions called index and privacy so here
whatever data is being passed will be
the model for these two pages or views
if we add a new controller here let's
say brew game controller then we will
have to add a new folder here called
again to add the views for that new
controller you will understand this more
once we start coding but I wanted to
give you a brief overview of all the
three folders that we have now let's
just understand how routing works in
typical MVC asp.net routing is a pattern
matching system which enables you to
match the incoming request to a
particular MVC action defined in a
controller when asp.net routing engine
receives a request at runtime it finds a
match against the URL pattern defined in
the round table if any match is found
then it forwards that request to the
controller otherwise it will return a
404 not found message when we will
create a new asp.net call MVC
application of outs are already added to
the project if we switch back to our
application and if we go on startup dot
CS right here where it's adding
controllers with view to our pipeline
and when we see the middlewares
we have first the app dot use routing
and we have the app dot use endpoints
now you can keep endpoints or you can
also use the routing without the
endpoints in versions 1 & 2 of asp.net
core this was a part of MVC but now it
is a separate piece of middleware to
make routing available to all the
middleware and not just MVC so that's
why we see AB not use routing on top and
then we have app dot use endpoints at
the bottom end point is a URL where
incoming requests will end up processing
by the middleware if you have used MVC
before you know that you have to specify
the routes folders and right here we are
specifying a default route in which if
nothing is defined it will look for the
home controller and it will call the
index action inside
that now asp.net core is not just MVC it
supports different technology which uses
routes like razor pages signal R and MVC
and the routing is different for each
one of them all of this tack uses middle
voice that registers the endpoints so if
you see here right now we only have the
MVC endpoint that is registered because
that is what we'll be using in this
application in previous version of
asp.net core routing was embedded in MVC
but that cannot work anymore since we
have more than one technology which uses
different types of routing first we will
do is we will add user routing which
will make the selected endpoint choices
available to all the middle verse that
follows after that and when we will do
use endpoints at that point we'll be
able to register and execute the
endpoints in lambda expression we have
several extension methods to register
endpoints one of them you can see here
is map controller route let's try to run
our application and see what happens
in the URL we do not have anything
defined it's just the domain name or
localhost and the port number in that
case if we go back it should go to home
controller index action so if we go on
solution Explorer inside home let me add
a debugger inside index and privacy
let's go back and press ENTER here you
can see it goes to the index action of
the home controller and when we continue
it will load the view for that so the
view if you go to solution Explorer
views home we have the index view right
here we have a welcome text and that is
what we see inside the UI when we click
on privacy the link goes to home
controller privacy action method and
then it should render
the page inside the home folder in views
and privacy page right here so if it
will continue here you can see home
privacy is loaded so the first one here
is the controller name and the later one
is the action method if you have not
defined anything it goes to the index
action by default so if you just define
home it goes to the home controller and
loads the index action method if you do
not define home as well it will go again
to the home controller index action
method and that is because you have
defined that in endpoint to use as a
default controller and action method so
this was a brief overview of routing in
MVC and we'll continue exploring this
more when we start building our
application now that we have the MVC
application created in this section we
will work on the same book list project
to perform all the crud operations but
we will use our MVC will be adding
models views and controllers and we'll
see how everything comes together let's
get started with that from the next
video now that we have brief overview of
our MVC project it's time to perform
crud operations on the pooka list again
so the first thing we will do is we will
add model for our book so we'll add a
new class we'll call it book and in here
we will add all the properties first
will be the ID so we can use key data
annotation and we'll call it prop
integer ID next we'll use the snippet
prop tab twice with a string name we can
copy this and paste this two more times
name property let me make it required
and the other one I'll change this to
author
and I ESPN this looks good for our model
once we have model in place we need to
add this to database so there are
multiple things that we have to do to
add it to database first in the models
will add our DB context class which we
will call application DB context in here
we need the constructor so CTO R and
within the constructor we need to pass
the dbcontext options we'll do control
dot here here we need to include the
package for Microsoft dot entity
framework or we'll find and install the
latest version you can do this by going
to the nougat package solution but I
want to do it right here directly here
we'll pass the application DB context
and we'll have options and we need to
pass it to the base class the same
options once we have that the
application dbcontext should inherit
from DB context now that application DB
context is looking good what we need is
we need to add our book to the database
so whenever we have to add a table will
add that property inside the application
dbcontext so we'll do prop this will be
of type D be set on book and let me call
this book's perfect this looks good for
our application DB context and this is
exactly what we did in racer pages as
well then the next thing is to add
connection string and to get the
connection string inside configure
services in startup dot CS so we'll go
to app setting start JSON and in here
let me page the connection string now
remember one thing that the server name
you have to double check so make sure if
you are using this connection string
copy the server name go to your sequel
server paste it here you just need one
backward slash and try to connect as
long as you're able to connect
you can use the same connection string
the project let me call this vocalist
MVC for the database name we have
trusted connection to true and multiple
active results adds to true great so
this looks good and the connection
string have been added in AB setting
start JSON exactly like we did increase
their pages the last thing that we have
to do is we need to configure startup
dot CS to use that connection string so
within the configure services we will
add services that add dbcontext in here
it will be on application dbcontext will
have to do a control dot here to include
models and we need to pass the options
for sequel server so options goes to
options dot use sequel server will have
to install a new NuGet package let me do
control dot here at him and I do not see
that neo get package here so what I will
do is I'll just go to tools they'll get
package manager solution and we'll
search for sequel server we have the
package which is Microsoft entity
framework or thought sequel server let's
install the latest version here perfect
it is installed now if we go back and if
we do control dot we'll see the using
statement for Microsoft entity framework
dot core and once we do that there we go
here we need to pass connection string
from the configuration so we'll do
configuration top we have a get
connection string here and we need to
pass the name inside our app settings
which is default connection we'll copy
that and paste it right here let me
break it in a new line there we go it
looks much better
this looks good for all the
configuration that we have to do but we
also want to add the razor compilation
package so right here let me add the
razor compilation package actually will
search for run time compilation there we
go and install the package this package
we are installing so that if the
application is running and we change
anything in the view and we refresh we
don't have to restart the application
whoops there we go and right here we
will to add razor run time compilation
great this is exactly what we did with
razor pages as well that's why I'm not
spending much time here once you do this
let's add a migration so we'll go to
tools nougat package manager console
will add migration ad book to DB and
here we see an added with the migration
that's because if we go to tools you'll
get package manager we have to install
package for entity framework tools so if
you search for entity framework
tools we'll install the Microsoft entity
framework or dot tools to our project
once that is installed then add
migration should work awesome let's go
back to package manager and hit the
command one more time this time it is
already building the project it was
successful and it adds a migration right
here great migration looks good let's
update the database to push apart model
to database it will first create that
database and then it will add the tables
great let's go back to make sure it's
working we'll go to database in sequel
server we have the new database in there
we have our table called books and great
we have all the columns as we wanted
once we add the bottle to our database
next thing let's go to our master page
which is underscored layout and let's
add a link for a new controller for our
book will copy the Ally here the new
controller let's call it books
controller and in there will have an
index action will call this as book list
and let's add a new controller inside
controllers we have the home controller
in here we'll add a new controller we'll
go with the empty controller for MVC and
we'll call this as books controller with
the name of the controller controller
has to be pre has to be added at the end
so whatever name you give before
controller will be the name of that
controller in this case it will be books
controller great our controller is added
and in here we have the index action
let's try to run our application and see
what happens
when you click on the link since we
already have index action in here it
will take you the books controller index
action but since we do not have any view
it will give an error that the View
index was not found it tried to look
inside views books indexed RCS HTML and
since it did not find it there it also
looked inside the shared folder so even
though we have the action method for
index we do not have the view to add a
view what you can do is inside our views
folder you can create a new folder with
the same name as your controller which
is books and in that you will have to
add index view you can do that in
solution Explorer or you can just right
click on index and click add view here
we'll go with the empty view and we do
not want it to be a partial view partial
view is something that you want when
you will be consuming that inside some
other view but in this case index will
have a page by itself
that being said we'll select use a
layout page because we want the same
header and footer for our index page as
well
let's hit add here perfect now if you
run the application and if you navigate
on the link you will see the word index
as you can see right here so we click
here and great we see our view in action
let's continue working here in the next
video now in this video since we have
our application running with the index I
want to install few third-party tools
first is a sweet alert that I want to
display nice alerts in our webpage next
is a toaster notification and in here if
we go to toaster jas we go to demo and
when you click show toast you see we
have nice toaster notifications here
we'll use this when we delete our poke
so we'll use toaster and the last one is
data tables here we get sorting
functionalities number of pages paging
functionality and search right out of
the box so we'll be using all three of
them now you can go here and get the CD
ends or I will have that attached with
the lecture so let me open that up and
within the attachments you will see CSS
underscore Jes we will copy the CSS
let's go back to our application and in
here let me close everything we'll be
adding that in our master page because
once we add in the master page it will
be accessible in all the other pages so
on top here we will be adding the CSS
and when we scroll down we have to add
the JavaScript so copy that and paste it
right here so perfect this looks good
and we have added all three of the
to our project now since our application
is already running in our racer pages
with index we use data tables and we
added a JavaScript we'll do the same in
this MVC project as well the JavaScript
will have the exact same functionalities
before we work on the JavaScript
let's work and create the action methods
inside our controller let's do that in
the next video now with an artbook
lished MVC project we want to work on
our controller which is the books
controller let me open up the Razr
project that we build in here I have
pulled up the Razr project in which we
added the API calls to get all of the
book as well as to delete a book this
calls will be exactly the same so we can
copy this and let me close that project
we'll switch back to our MVC project and
within our books controller since those
are API calls we will create a region
here and we'll call it API calls I will
end the region as well and between that
we will paste the code that we copied
now first thing in controller when we
have to access database we need the
application dbcontext so we'll have
private read-only application and
dbcontext
we will do a control dot to include
using book list MVC dot models and we'll
call this underscore dB we need to get
this using dependency injection so we'll
create a constructor here and we will
have the application dbcontext DB and
will to underscore DB is equal to DB
this you must be familiar by now that we
need to do this to get the DB context
using dependency injection
then if we scroll down rather than book
what we have is books inside our
application dbcontext then for two lists
and async will do control dot to include
Microsoft dot entity framework or we'll
make books in all the places other than
that everything will be same for get all
and delete api's once we have that then
inside index when we return back to the
view we do not want to pass anything
here because we will be loading this
view using the API call right here with
the help of data table so let me go to
the view and in here we need to add us
for our JavaScript that being said the
JavaScript will be exactly same with one
or two modifications as compared to a
result code so I have that in the
attachments as well which is exactly
same as what we have in the raiser
project we will copy this go to solution
Explorer
ww root Jas we will add a new item and
this will be a JavaScript and we'll call
this book list dot J s let me page the
code that we copied all we have to
change here is URLs all that was changed
here was the URLs here we had API
forward slash books inside raiser pages
but in MVC we do not have that we are in
the books controller and if we want to
call any action method in here all we
need is the controller name followed by
the action name so the API calls are get
all and delete because of which if we go
to book list rjs to get all of the books
we are calling
books which is the controller name
followed by the action name which is get
all that will retrieve all of the books
then when we have to edit the book we
are calling the control
and then right here you see an action
name which is absurd we do not have this
action yet but we will add this in the
upcoming videos largely you see inside
the delete here we are calling the books
controller and then the delete action
method with an ID which we are passing
which is the ID of the book so if we go
to books controller we have the delete
action and here we are expecting an ID
so you can see the chain is exactly
similar as we did inside the raiser
pages that being said our JavaScript is
in place and our controller API are in
place all we have to do is we need to
add the table and call our JavaScript in
index let's do that in the next video in
this video let's modify the index view
and see how it looks
we do not need a model in this because
we'll be loading everything using data
tables with additive give it a class of
container and role and give it padding:0
and margin:0 within this main div we'll
add a div with class of column 6 and
we'll have our title here we'll use
bootstrap class for text info and we'll
call this book list after this column 6
let me add another div give it a class
of column 6 and here I want the button
rather than 6 here let me make it column
3 and offset it by 3 and we will add a
button or a link here now this link I
want us to redirect to an absurd page
where we can create a new book so in
order to redirect just like we had ASB
page inside raiser pages in MVC we have
ASP action let's see if you want to
redirect to action in a different
controller we also have ASP controller
so here
you can write books controller in there
we have the absurd action which we will
add then we will add some porch club
classes BT and BT and info and we'll
give it form control will also make it
text off-white there we go
and in here I will display add new book
now in this case since the absurd action
will also be added inside the books
controller it is okay if you do not
write this so this is optional but I
will leave it there after the stiff let
me add another div and this time I'll
give it a class of column 12 for our
main table along with column 12 I will
add border and I will give padding 3
then here we want our main table we'll
give it an ID that we have inside
publish Jes which is DT underscore load
will copy and paste it will add some
bootstrap classes like table table
striped and table order whoops
table ordered along with that I'll also
add a style to give it a width of 100%
perfect here we will add tea head for
the headings in which we'll add the
table row we'll have the th tag we want
to display name author ISBN and buttons
to edit and delete so ISBN author and
the last one will have the buttons to
edit and delete that being said we need
our reference to book list yes so we'll
add section scripts in here we will add
the script tag add an SRC for JavaScript
book list dark GS once you do all of
that
that's one our application and
see how things look let's go to polish
here and great it's loading and no data
found that's because we have not added
any book yet but we can see the data
table is loading as expected if you
click on add your book it will give an
added because we have not added that
action method or that view in the next
video let's work on the absurd get
action method and the view in this video
let's work and create an absurd get
action method absurd view will be used
for two places one to edit a book and
want to create a book based on that
sometimes it will retrieve an ID if it
is for edit if it is for create there
won't be any ID so we can copy this
index paste it here and we'll call this
action method as absurd in here
parameter it can receive an ID or it
cannot so we'll make this a nullable
parameter that being said now you need a
book object with absurd so we can add
that book object right here will do prop
it will be a book object and we'll call
this book now we can use find property
here and once you bind that property on
post you won't have to retrieve that it
will automatically be binded that things
are inside the view here first let's
initialize the book is equal to new book
and then we will check here if ID is
equal to null if this is null that means
this is for a create request and we will
return back to the view the book object
which is just a new object if this is
not the case that means this is for an
update if someone wants to update a book
we need to retrieve all the data for
that book
database and we have to display that so
we will retrieve that in poke here from
DB dot we have the books object or model
and we just want to retrieve one book so
we can use first or default here and
we'll say u goes to u dot ID is equal
equal to the ID that we retrieve right
here after that we can check here if
book is equal equal to null if this is
not that means there is no book in the
database and we will just return not
found if we find that book will return
back to the absurd view but we will
populate the book which we have
retrieved from the database so the view
will expect a book regardless of if it
is used for create or update this looks
good for the absurd get action method in
the next video let's have the absurd
view in this video let me add the absurd
view we can right click on the action
method and we'll click add view this
looks good let's add this now the absurd
view first thing what will be the model
if we take a look at the books
controller we are passing a book object
to the view so that will be the model so
we'll define mortal it is book list MVC
dot models dot book we'll add a br and
we'll add heading here give it a class
of text info here we want to display
edit book or create book based on the
request if we go back to our controller
if ID is now then we pass the book
object with a null ID so if ID is null
then it is a create request so right
here
now will be 0 so we can check at and
we'll say if model dot ID does not equal
to 0
if it is not zero then display added
else we will just display create along
with that we want to display book this
way the single line will surf both
create an edit book to display the title
we will add BR here and we'll add a mean
div give it a class of border and we'll
add container we will give it a style
for padding of 30 pixels within here let
me add a form tag and will give method
of post so that whenever a user submits
the button it will go to the post action
method for absurd inside the books
controller here you can also define the
action method as absurd but since we are
on the absurd if you do not define this
that will also work if it was some other
action method as compared to the name
then you would have to define it but in
this case we are good now when we will
be posting it we will need the ID if the
ID is not know so we'll add an at F here
and we'll check if model dot ID is not
zero then I want to store that ID in an
hidden property so input type is equal
to hidden ASP four will be the ID then
just like razor pages we want
validations here so we'll add class of
text danger and we'll use ASP validation
summary for model only then we'll start
displaying our property in class of form
group and row and in each one of them
we'll add a div give it a class of
column three first we want to display
label with ASP for this will be mean and
we'll add a div give it a class of
column six in here we want the input
type so input ASP for tag helper this
will be for name of the book and we'll
give it a class
form control along with that we will add
a span with ESP validation for for our
name and we'll give it a class of text
danger this looks good for our first
property let me copy this and paste it
two more times let me do it three times
actually after name
we have author will copy this and paste
it here and we have ISBN we'll copy and
paste it here once we complete the ISBN
next will be button to create or update
and a link to go back to the page so
we'll have column three here let me also
make it an offset of three and this one
will be three in here let me add a
button of type submit' since we are in a
form this will be good we'll add VT n VT
and primary and form control then what
we want to display in button is we want
the same logic that we had right here so
we can copy this and we'll paste it here
rather than edit we will display update
or create next is a link to go back so
right here you can display an anchor tag
with the tag helper ASP action if we
click this action we want to go to the
index action of books controller since
we are already in books controller it's
okay if you do not write ASP controller
here and just ASP action is sufficient
we'll add some bootstrap classes here et
NBT and success and form control and
we'll display back to list that being
said let's save this and let's run our
application in here if you go to book
list and we do not have any data let's
add a new book and hit create great we
have the validations but when we head it
goes back we do not
want that so for that we will add the
scripts right here so we'll add section
scripts and in here with a at partial
name of if we go to our shared we have
validation scripts partial let me to
rename and copy this and we'll paste it
right here let's run our application and
give this another try
let's go to book list let's try to add
one head create this time it did not do
a postback and displayed the validation
we will fill in some details and hit the
create nothing will happen the reason is
we have not configured the post action
method for observed let's do that in the
next video now that we have added the
absurd view what will happen when we hit
the button with all the details for that
we need to add an absurd post action
method so we can just copy this and
we'll paste it one more time this time
we need to mention that this is an HTTP
POST this time we need to mention that
this is an HTTP POST and with post
methods we have to use validate anti
forgery token to use the inbuilt
security to prevent some attacks that
being said in absurd right here you can
use book and will retrieve the object
like this when we use submit with the
form but if you go to the top right here
you are using mind property because of
which you do not need this you can
directly access the book object that we
have inside our controller now within
the absurd what is the first thing that
you should check we should check if
model state is valid or not
so if model state is valid only then
proceed further if it is valid then we
will check here if both dot ID
is equal equal to 0 if this is 0 this
means it is a create and we will to
underscore DB books dot ad and we will
add the book object there else it is for
an update so will to underscore T V dot
books dot we have an update method in
here and we just need to pass the object
that has to be updated it will update
this based on the ID inside this book
object once all of the system we need to
do underscore DB dot save changes to
push all the changes to our database
once the changes have been pushed we
want to return but in raiser pages we
were using redirect to page in MVC we
will use redirect to action and we can
redirect to the index action so what it
will do is after it saves the changes it
redirects to the index action here and
it will load all of the books again from
the database this looks good
let's run this and give this a try let's
go to book list here add a new book we
will fill in some details and hit the
create button great you can see our data
tables is also working with the new book
let's try to update this you can see
create and edit both the functionalities
are working as expected the only thing
that is remaining is delete here now
when you click on delete you see a nice
sweet alert and if you click OK here it
should delete the book and it displays
nice toaster notification you can see
our create edit as well as delete are
working as expected
now with this you can see how we can
perform current operations on book list
using an MVC project and this is just
the beginning that is
much more to explore in asp.net core
whether you go with MBC or praiser pages
what we just learned is the tip of the
iceberg so if you are interested in
learning more about MVC or raiser pages
I have many more in-depth courses in
which we will be building real-world
application but that's all we had for
this course and good luck with your
future projects